using this dy on DX notation they want
us to find under business over here so
it's a bit easier to read find thee and
then they introduce a couple of words
one of which you definitely know and one
in which you may have any counted a lot
of you wouldn't the taejun what is that
what is that agent it's that it's that
special line that just touches it just
touches onto your curve okay so that's
all what a tangent is has anyone
encountered the word normal yet in
physics it's a thing that's react yeah
okay so let's have a look at this draw
for me just any curve if you like any
curve you like and I'm pick a point on
your curve like say here and draw in the
tangent you know what the tangent looks
like so it's going to sort of go off all
right there we go and it's going just
touch there okay now the normal is very
closely related to the tangent it'll go
through the same spot right there that
we've just picked but the difference is
yeah it's at right angles so it's
perpendicular to this tangent so if I
put in a new line here like so and I put
it in at right angles so this guy here
is the normal will come to calculating
that a bit later on let's just focus on
the tangent first okay so they want us
to find the tangent by which they mean
find an equation of the tangent to each
curve there's a curve for Part C at the
point indicated so then they provide us
this set of coordinates J I think is it
negative 1 0 yeah negative ones here
good okay so when we have a look at this
because all which hinging is the
notation this is going to look just like
what we did before all of the machinery
is the same we're just going to write it
very differently slightly so I want the
equation the tangent I've already got a
point
that this tangent apparently goes
through so what are the piece of
information do I need along with that
point what other information do I need
to find the equation of this line
I think I need the gradient right like
that's what makes this tangent the
tangent for example this blue line I've
just drawn it also goes through that
point but it's not the tangent because
it doesn't have the right gradient so
because we're interested in gradient
that's why I'm going to differentiate
I've got y equals this so I'm going to
use my dy on DX notation to indicate the
derivative okay
can we differentiate this please x
squared what to do with that
2x thank you very much that twos come
out the front power is reduced by one so
now it's 2x to the power of one which I
don't need to write and then my next
term is right fantastic
so we're starting to get a little bit
comfortable you're like I know how to do
with this my brain is getting more used
to this process okay so what we've got
here is the gradient function it's not
the gradient it's the gradient at any
particular spot that's why it can change
according to X what am I going to put
into it to get the gradient I want ya
the relevant x-coordinate of your point
there now look carefully you've got two
numbers here negative 1 and zero which
one we gonna use the negative 1 why is
that that's the X it's that's what its
dependent on right so this is all the
Nexus so I'm going to say when x equals
negative 1
when x equals negative 1 dy on DX equals
and then I'm going to substitute in as
always when you're doing substitution
even you can evaluate it straight in
your head right the substitution is
there please so I'm gonna go to lots of
negative 1 take away 4 lots of negative
1 cubed and I know you might be able to
do some of that in your head but just
have a look at this like particularly
the second half of the line you are
begging to make some mistake with the
minus signs there if you try and do this
in your head especially when you're
rushed under exam conditions now I've
written it down 2 times negative 1 is 2
this next bit here
this is gonna be minus 4 times negative
1 which is as rastan said plus 4 and
I've got none so what do I do with this
thing this number 2
that's the gradient right the gradient
at this point with two so now all I need
to say is the tangent is because that's
the thing I'm working at now and I'm
going to use that form of the equation
of a straight line which takes the
gradient and the point what's that form
called point gradient cuz gonna point at
a great here and it is a constant value
under fish that y minus y1 which in this
case is what's y1 it's that that
y-coordinate this a zero it equals
what's on the other side the gradient M
which in this case is 2 outside of X
minus negative 1 I'm even gonna write
that X minus negative one like so okay
again if you feel like you can say I can
write that as X plus 1 that's fine but
I'm doing this so that I know I've
gotten the equation right and then I'll
simplify y equals this is said again
sorry it didn't ask us to find the
gradient is that your question say that
again yeah it said it just said find the
tangent which is very very broad right
yeah that's okay it just says find the
tangent that sort of implies I want the
equation of the tangent but to get that
I do need the gradient as part of it
does that make sense because you're
right it didn't tell us but we needed to
and I think tsunami already said this is
going to be 2x times X plus 1 which is
2x plus 2 you happy with that okay now
just put your clothes down for a minute
I just want you to look up and I want to
indicate a couple of things a couple of
errors on so much errors they just pour
an unclear setting out which mrs. ladies
and I we've both seen hundreds and
thousands of times so I'm going to make
like a big deal about them and tell you
not to do them okay so here's the first
big common mistake that we see we see
people get this thing get this equation
they write that down they're like oh
this is the thing I have to
differentiate because so frequently like
by the end of this course you will have
differentiated things tens of thousands
of times you're already thinking I need
to find the derivative so your brain
immediately says I'm just gonna find the
derivative and that is the derivative
but this is not equal to this right
these are not the same thing the
cool sign does not mean what's my next
step the equal sign means these two
things are identical right so that's why
it's really important that you're
actually right this is what I'm
calculators that make sense
pressin okay so if you wanted and I
guess I mean like I said before if the
question provides it to you in F of X's
go ahead use what they've got but if
they're provided to you is why my next
line can't say f dash because there is
no f of X in this question right unless
I said that this equal f of X and then
off you go but why introduced an
indication when you sort of already have
one that's suited for the purpose does
that make sense that is another common
error by the way people will write
instead of this because they like this
original notation they'll just write
this and the mark will be like wait
because this come from right what what
is this referring to it's not free to
anything in the question so it's not
valid in this context so there's the
first mistake just just saying eCourse
because it's so the next thing that
you're thinking of please don't do that
the second thing that people will do is
in they'll say okay I don't just want
the general derivative
I want the gradient at a particular
point and the point is x equals negative
1 right so then people immediately write
that like they found their derivative
like so and then they just say it's
equal to and they just start
substituting stuff in okay now say
against right well now the market
because we've seen this so many times
right we kind of know what you were
trying to do but we also know this is
not actually the case because is that
the gradient function of our original
function it's not because the gradient
function of this changes and this is
just like a particular place so it's a
common thing for people to just say oh
my next thing is I'm gonna put in a
value but it's actually a whole
different thing that's why I went to the
effort and I hope you've done this
already to say when X is a certain value
then you say the derivative is this ok
and then the last thing is and you might
notice there's a common theme here right
the last thing is people don't
a what they do next they're just like oh
I'm supposed to find the line now and
then this algebra just appears out of
nowhere right now if you've just got a
whole bunch of equal signs going down
the page with no other explanation
then I'm expecting what you mean is all
of these things are the same but you're
calculating separate things all the way
through can someone tell me how many
distinct steps with it what was the
first step yep differentiate so find the
gradient function always step two
finally great at a particular place and
then a whole separate step three is now
gonna put that all together okay so I
want to see that you have three steps of
logic in there so that I understand all
this isn't cleaner is what they're doing
they're not just kind of mechanistically
going through a purpose because that's
what they saw in the textbook you know
why you're doing these three steps and
that's why you say it okay